dea
2012年2月19日南小学校にて
みんなどう原先生にあのすんごく楽しみにしてるよ今日はスーパー元気だは1年生の
教室に向かう途中
多田先生はそう言ってにっこりと笑った多田先生はインフレ所よく使う40代後半と帽
式黒髪の女性が人生のた
アイアン小学生と一緒に過ごしてきたせいかん
恋慕小学国語辞典に載っている言葉しか使わずすごいというふうに形容詞をよく伸ばす
たとえ相手が郵便局の配達員であってもだ
みんな昨日からどう言説に早く会いたいって言ってるわ
そうですか楽しみですね笑いながらも僕は同機が葉
下宿なるのを感じた小学1年生の授業は初めてだ
どうなるか分からない道元先生ここですいや
1 a と書かれた教室の前でたちともふと思い出して僕は音先生に話しかけた
アルファベットの練習のことで使おうた先生をいきなりガッツポーズをして僕の言葉を
遮りん
ガラガラと教師
喉はを左へと滑らせた中を見て
僕はあっけにとられたアフリカのサバンナ見渡す限り
人気の内装原中央には大きな水たまりがあってその中でハヌかけたカバと巨大なヘビが
暴れている尿土地が四方に飛び散っている水たまりの右側ではハイエナが走り回って
いる
7法堂合いそうだその横ではボクシングす
るように後ろ足で立って格闘しているライオンおはようございます
カイリ隊員もすごく帰りたいと思いつつ仕方なく狂気の中に足を踏み入れる
動物園の匂いが反応作っ
とにかく髪へ僕は水たまりの左手に視線を綴るの供養しきった大木
その枝によじ登る3匹のサルコ添えのてっぺんにはでっかいオランウータンライオン
たちに向かって風曲げている何ですかこれ僕は思わずそう言うと多田先生のホーム9
そこで自分のすぐ後ろに像が歩いていることに気づ
時心臓が飛び出しそうになる1もう退院笑みを絶やさないをた先生像が去っていくのを
見計らいつつ僕はもう一度聞く生徒たちは毒束太田先生はぐふふっと笑った
道元先生のそういう上古いうところ良いですね答えになっていない答えに不安のつの
水たまりの方に
目をやるとカバがヘビに噛み付いて人では今から同原潜せいか体の部分を紹介してくれ
ますもうず
東た先生の方に視線を戻す同源先生のソングをしっかり聞きましょう
自分の歌があったことに驚くとともに授業計画にないことをと思う氏に師事してくるを
た先生にない支部と
するされの1壁がバク宙して水たまりに飛び込んたを厳選ついうのを忘れたけどヘッド
ショールターズ兄残土等ず立ってくれますかヘッドショルダーずに残土東山蛇に歌えと
もちろんいいですよもらって答える牧夫をた先生はてで目がも付く
みんな立って standing up いつのまにかよくになっていたライオンたち
は興味なさそうにこちらを見てしばらくするとまた視線を外して欠伸をした
じゃあお願いしますね同原潜つ深呼吸する
a
超ですマイター
次のサビお願いします andi 前劉禅 nerf ナーフランタンがこちらに
向かって歩を投げ始めた
20ずニーズセンターやっぱり楽しいね
桃源先生200種某た先生は僕の鼻先でてを打ち鳴らした無性に腹が立って僕はもうず
そのシワのよった指に噛み付きそうになったんで
はもう1回やってみましょう今度早くさあ準備はいいですか
いっきまーす別号動物たちにそう叫ぶともうた先生は僕の方に向き直りじゃあお願いし
ますね
と小声で言った教室の向こうでは像が足を使うみたいに水たまりに枚足を浸した僕は
もう一度息を吸ったあーへ
ちょうどいい
兄前途んずないうんが一頭立ち上がり急にまっすぐこちらに突進してくる太田先生は
笑ってだねーよと指を振った興毅くん同源先生に触っちゃいけないよなぁをこう聞くと
思しき乱用は一旦足を止める
じっとこちらを見ている兄前頭再び動き始め後期来てばもう
どうぞ続けてください峠全然 ae 所 this 2020ライオンは足を速め a
大神龍線マーテルの宇宙へ飛ぶや果皮ちょうど2分た僕のひざに規模突っ込んだ
リーズ
ニーズん
ni
[音楽]